foreign
is here in Tokyo today it's been a big
diplomatic Whirlwind for him this week
he had zelenski at Checkers on Monday
then he went to the Council of Europe in
Reykjavik to talk to EU leaders mainly
about migration from his perspective and
now here in Tokyo he's having bilateral
meetings with the Japanese today to talk
about deepening defense and economic
ties between our two Nations the big
announcement is 18 billion pounds of
additional investment from Japan into
the UK which the Prime Minister will no
doubt Lord as an important moment in our
post-brexit trading Arrangements
prime minister
also a naval base
in Japan why is he doing it well there's
a big defense Accord being announced
between the two countries the Hiroshima
Accord and this is all about deepening
defense ties between the UK and Japan
why because there is growing concern
about the threat of China and rise in
China aggression in this region the
indo-pacific region so there's a deal
there between the Brits and the Japanese
[Music]
three big elements I think of this G7
Summit in Hiroshima the fast will be
about
economic cooperation there might be
discussion about the US and the risk of
debt default that's a massive issue for
the global economy number two on the
gender clearly is Ukraine the G7 is so
aligned but what about other countries
in the southern hemisphere that are more
aligned if you like with China and
Russia so look out for talks with Brazil
with India can they get them to be a bit
more sympathetic if you like to the G7
view of how the world should approach
Russia with regards to Ukraine and then
the third issue is China and so can the
G7 agree a form of words about their
approach to China there have been some
disagreements macron is saying that he
doesn't believe Europe should get
involved in crises that are not ours
they were his words on a visit to China
last month whereas President Biden has
made it very clear that the US is
prepared to defend Taiwan against any
sort of attack from China so can the
Allies agree watch for language around
de-risking
de-risking strategy rather than
decoupling from China so look out for
that that would be big on this agenda